30 rock I cannot believe 30 rock it's  been four years since that show went off  the air I'm just curious because  obviously so many talented people  associated with that show but do you  miss Tracy Morgan being a regular part  of your life I do miss that man I call  him on his birthday I call everybody on  the birthday  I called Tracy on his birthday back in  November it was like hey Tracy it's me  happy birthday  yo Kenneth I just got to say man I love  you thank you for this I'm like oh my  name is Jack Kenneth was the name of  your character I know that how many  years did he work with you mostly on  this show yeah please please I am  pleased we've taken good care of you  over the years  you